- Dude.
Hey, you going to Ray's party?
Yeah, I'm going.
You know,
Amy's gonna be there.
Yeah, I know.
Things have been
real good with her, man.
Tonight could be the night.
Could be.
Dude, are you okay?
Not really, dude.
What's wrong?
You get the hottest girl
at a party with no parents.
You're definitely gonna hit that
for sure tonight, man.
You're gonna lose
that v for good!
[slams]
My penis is white.
Excuse me?
I have a white penis.
What?
But you're black.
Nuh-uh. I'm bi-racial.
All the white went straight
to my penis.
That--what--what,
you mean, like, the color?
Oh.
Yeah.
But wait, dude.
I mean, how bad could it be?
It's bad.
How bad?
It's like a snickers.
Regular or fun size?
Which one do you get
at halloween?
Fun size.
That's the one.
[Bleep]
I know.
What am I gonna do?
I mean, I...
How am I gonna hit it with amy
with my little white penis?
Everyone's gonna find out
and I'm never gonna hear
the end of it.
Dude, dude, dude.
Amy's white.
She's not gonna care.
Really?
Yeah.
She's white.
I guess you're right.
I mean, she's probably not even
gonna know the difference.
Nah, man.
White girl, white penis.
You're all good.
[bell rings]
Hey, there he is.
How'd it go last night?
Don't wanna talk about it.
Well, what happened?
Black vagina.